well he was done with that conversation
yeah yeah clearly that President Obama I
mean he talked about the warmth of that
relationship that is no longer the case
he thinks basically what he's said
before which is that President Obama as
he wrote in that tweet bugged him or
tapped his that it not bugged him but
tapped his tapped him that's how he put
it it would have been interesting here
but he clearly didn't want to answer the
question but I'm curious about how you
find him found him because there seemed
to be two views on one
he's supremely confident very confident
the job that he does and will tell you
that he's doing a good job on the other
he seems to be wrestling with the
realities and the confines of this
office he is Supriya he is absolutely
confident I think what he's wrestling
with is the constraint all presidents
wrestle with the men strains but I think
he's also in some cases doesn't want to
talk about those constraints because
part of what he talks about is written
about and has in his private business
career talked about is the the power of
the image and so you want to look as in
his view of it at least in our
conversations like you've got the world
by the tail when that ended were you
escorted out did someone lift you from
the ground and show you the door I think
it was it was pretty clear that I was to
escort myself at or I would be I would
be asked when I would be moved along it
was a very good interview it was time
for our conversation to be over very
very good interview thanks John thank
you John